hey guys it's Greg Alba here with Joey
my reason hi the channel shut up and
dance you shut up and dance
yeah that sort of thing that's where she
says is ever happy yeah you shut up and
dance
you shut up that's cool yeah cuz they
forget that they just said it to you
yeah I met Julie and Switzerland right I
was like this is my first time seeing
Greg in American America states the
Trump States yeah so I've invited her
over today she's never done any kind of
reaction videos before so I thought okay
we'll do a good warm-up a good warm-up
it's the short film that came out on
August 9th 2015 from the channel [ __ ]
you zombie called selfie from Hell it's
only a minute and 40 seconds it can't be
that scary oh I've never seen this I
haven't seen you there it's like very
organic
oh yeah it's part of the wrong I'm
scared I'm scared already
oh my god my hands are climbing look at
that yeah yeah
oh my god well I take the time to see
your man
run everyone's a Dominus carry movie
where did she fall yeah take another
photo she's gonna take a third selfie
attempt this is like stupid and scary at
the same time
that's pretty scary oh my god it's Mike
was on right yep it was the volume there
ice cream - oh that was pretty scary I
wasn't expecting it to be that scary I
was like simultaneously obviously
expecting something no matter but at the
same time it was still the suspense was
there that I'm like oh my god I don't
know how she could have been that dumb
from the first shot she fell down and
there was no reason but she didn't trip
on me she literally just turned and was
like oh I'm scared I'm gonna fall like
at this moment right here between 22
seconds 37 seconds she's like zooming in
like huh-huh there's no one there it's
okay
how could she just let that go just go
I'm gonna get back to the turning this
guy honorary yeah that's what's wrong
with women get that horny they'd get
irrational make dumb decisions okay
first how many big dumb guys have you
slept with just because you got a little
excited you know I was very irrational
okay we're getting like so off-topic but
wrong there she's too horny this one
made a bad decision it's true don't be
that was don't be horny women are not
allowed to be trumps America she did
that was a cool jump scare though
because yeah you would think like it
would just appears a little closer or
something like I didn't imagine actually
coming out grabbing her and biting her
that was pretty scary this was in time
for Halloween wasn't it well it came out
2015 of August oh oh yeah this is like
almost a year and a half old
oh wow yeah watching it 18 million eight
hundred sixty seven thousand eight
hundred fourteen News we are the 18th
million eight hundred sixty seven
thousand eight hundred fifteen TV
but we took we stole of you because
there's two of us in one computer that's
true I should have brought my own yeah I
should do the reaction videos no watch
on your computer okay so boobs and scary
things are what does well on YouTube
that's today's lesson Julie if you're
new to the channel subscribe today get
accepted you fellow
reject you Julie Zhong is not called
Julie's on anywhere and has boobs she's
on YouTube I was a YouTube shut up and
dance and she is on Instagram and
Twitter dance juju dance it's like me
telling myself to go down it's weird
wow you're making it very complicated to
be famous yeah but you become the only
Julie's on that when other people hear
of a Julie's on they go oh are you
related to that Julie's on just like how
when people here my name is Greg Alba
people go are you related Jessica do
they do that
I see that never crossed my mind it
crosses almost everyone's mind
Wow and yes she makes my sister and my
wife what that's why she has the same
last name as me good day people